- The story of "Little Voice" is Bess and
people around Bess finding their voice.
- I just don't have that thing.
- You're way too hard on yourself.
- We knew, obviously, this was
going to be a story,
this young woman
growing up in New York,
and that meant it had to
look like it does,
which is to say a cast that
looks like the city.
Every background, every color,
every religion, every sexual orientation.
- There is something so magical
about their chemistry.
You really felt like there was
a deep sense of trust between them.
- It was just a really
warm, familial set,
and that's the kind of set
that I like to create.
- We're in this together.
- My character Prisha is a musician
struggling in New York city,
and she's also coming to terms
with her sexuality.
- Who you are isn't a choice.
It's who you are.
- That's part of the reason why
I wanted to play Ethan.
He experienced, actually,
quite horrible hardships,
and what's so nice about him
is how hopeful he is.
And that's what the show is, isn't it?
It's about finding the courage
to do what you believe in,
and to not be led astray.
- I think I'm just scared.
- Everybody's scared.
- ♪ There is enough,
so ask for more ♪
- You... got to do this.
- We're just this young,
diverse group of people
trying to find our footing, not
just in New York, but in life.
We all have a lot of heart,
and we all love what we do,
and it shows.
Whoo!
- We've had such a wide range
of incredible actors
portraying the characters
and what they go through.
How do we get to Neverland?
- Second star to the right and
straight on 'til morning.
You just gain a new friendship
along the way,
with all these different
personalities coming together as one.
It makes the show feel complete.
Take it away, Bess.
- ♪ There is enough ♪
- It's been really
eye-opening for me
in being pushed into the deep end
with this show.
And it's the kind of magic you
don't find all the time.
- You find the people
who believe in you,
and it helps you
believe in yourself at times,
and I think that's
a really beautiful way
for us to engage with each other
and the world.
- We're on our own now.
This is our time.
- ♪ I want more ♪